مبنى البرلمان هذا على ضفافه نهر التايمز
والمطل على ساعه بيغ بان من المعالم
التاريخيه الشهيره في العالم وواجهه
سياحيه لملايين السياح من كل مكان لكن هذا
الصرح مهدد بالانهيار
[موسيقى]
فتقرير للجنه المحاسبه العامه بمجلس
العموم التي تدقق في مصاريف البرلمان خلص
بان خطه الترميم المبنى الواجب اعتمادها
بطيئه في التعامل مع احداث من تسرب المطر
من السقف وسقوط قطع من البناء الى الجدران
الملوث بماده
بصحه العاملين بداخله والحرائق المتفرقه
هذا بشهادات مسؤولين على ترميم وتجديد
البرلمان المعروف بقصر وسميستر في
افاداتهم امام اللجنه البرلمانيه المعنيه
امن ولكنهم متداعن في مناطق رئيسيه معينه
وبحاجه ماسه الى الترميم ومن اجل الحفاظ
على سلامته على سبيل المثال من خطر نشوب
حريق كارثي يتعين علينا القيام بدوريات
عديده حيث ليس لدينا نظام قوي لمن عند
دلاع الحرائق وانتشارها
لجنه المحاسبه تلوم سنوات من المماطله بعد
تحديد مجلس النواب قبل خمس سنوات لمسار
العمل الذي يكلف مليوني جنيه استرليني في
الاسبوع على مدى سبعه اعوام وخاصه النواب
الذين يرفضون الانتقال الى مباني اخرى ما
سيرفع تكلفه الترميم وصيانه المبنى الى
اكثر من 20 مليارا ويستغرق عشرات السنين
اذا استمرت الجلسه الصاخبه في البرلمان
اثناء عمليه الترميم
برلمان بريطانيا ام البرلمانات في العالم
وواجهه البلاد في الخارج بنيته التحتيه
تتاكل وقد يتعرض للتدمير قبل اصلاحه ما لم
يتوقف المسؤولون والنواب عن تجاوز
المسؤوليه بشان مخاوف التكاليف الباهظه
لعمليه الترميم في زمن التقشف مصطفى زاروا
العربيه لندن لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات